thank you so much for being here um
congratulations on such a a powerful and
like I said timely film
um I guess we should start with Ali
because I know this film is based on the
real story of the spider killer uh Syed
Hane who killed 16 women between 20 000
and 2001.
um when did you first sort of hear about
his story were you aware of it growing
up was it something that was you know uh
sort of in in the zeitgeist
yeah I mean
um hi everyone I
um of course
you know this was a huge case
um the actual case which were inspired
by
um when it happened
um
you know in terms of the scale of it
only you know
um this guy as you were mentioning
killed 16 people in a year
and you know obviously it was covered by
the media and you know it was out there
but but I have to say like if you want
to compare it with you know
say like an American Standard you know
this would have been national news like
every day if this would happen in
Alabama or Vermont or whatever but this
was a bit different in Iran also because
I think that there was a sense that the
government didn't want it to like give
it more space one of the reasons or you
know being because the city of mashat
where this happened it's a um it's a
special place you know I can get into
that later
and why and how and also the fact that
there were sensitivities around the city
and to to present it in a very like
positive way and also the fact that the
the in the actual case said the guy who
he was a very devote religious guy
and for the government to sort of accept
you know that that you know the media is
writing about this devote Muslim that
has killed so many people it was just
like
I think they were not you know they were
reluctant to say the least for for the
news to sort of spread out but that
being said yeah I mean um you know me
and my friends I was living in Tehran at
the time we were discussing this
constantly and we're discussing like how
it's going to happen and you know when
they when he was caught
um you know there was this sense that he
could get away you know because as crazy
as it sounds there was there has been
precedence about you know this happening
this sort of murder happening and then
people would refer to some fatwa or some
sort of you know a religious cleric
uh you know the religious sermon saying
like they were
inspired by that and they sort of acted
upon something that they thought was
lawful
and you know in some cases they could
actually get away with
so this was not completely you know
unprecedented
yeah and Azar you have the greatest
story ever of how you came to star in
this movie for which I should mention
you won the best actress award at can
congratulations
um thank you you came to it first as the
casting director when you were I don't
want to say just casting because that's
a huge job as well but what was it about
this story and script that immediately
sparked you
well uh yeah I'm basically actress but
then when I heard about Alice project I
when he was looking for casting director
and I immediately it suggested myself
uh I I know the story I was leaving that
time in Iran and uh you know they feared
the the whole atmosphere for me was
really familiar and I really wanted to
just for the first time at least once
you know being involved in a diaspora
movie
in a very correct way because I have
this critical uh with Iranian movies
outside Iran always you know I don't
believe in them especially because of
actors and accent body language and
all these and
you know as a woman I think this story
is important and I remember that time
we had you know as Eddie says everyone
was kind of we couldn't believe that
this guy is just killing these women 16
women in a year and nobody is stopping
and I I personally I had this impression
that someone from government to support
him and you know there there were for me
I I had many doubts about this project
about this story and I think this
project when I came on board and I
started my
um
research and there is a documentary on
this story and kind of many documents
newspapers photos and you know I heard
about all these prostitutes stories and
watched some documentaries about them
and you know that helped me
to understand it better and that's why I
think still important to watch it
because it's kind of you know you we can
make it
it's it's especially with it's amazing
because I don't know if you know I I
think somehow you all know there is a
big demonstration in Iran every day and
it's been I think since months ago and
you know somehow this movie is just
coming out everywhere in Europe in the
U.S in this
atmosphere and and more than ever I
think this movie is important and this
story is important it's really related
to this to women situation I really
didn't want to make a movie feminist
movie or a movie about women but in the
end for me this movie is
really related to women's stories and
you know it's about women and the way he
he just made it without hijab without
any censorship
somehow we see their body their hair
their skin and you know every time I
remember how he filmed everything you
know even with dragging me with the
journalists
you know you feel this skin you feel
there
their body and the
that's why I think you know from the
beginning the story was anyway important
and today it's for me you know more than
ever
something you know we have something to
tell with this story you know it's
opportunity to have this movie
these these days because we can just
talk about these women in Iran and I
believe you two work together for for
years as casting director and director
at what point did it shift it was pretty
late in the game wasn't it yeah it took
three years actually this casting you
know we decided to do from the beginning
we just
we didn't want to go for those supers
Iranian Stars
and somehow we decided to you know
gather a cast a mix of actors and
non-actors
and at some point Heidi went to Iran and
I organized the week of audition there
with Iranian stage actors and
you know actors from Cinema and that's
amazing too because For the First Time I
I think actors from inside of Iran they
they just wanted them they accepted to
work and you know to be involved in the
international movie which is a bit
problematic anyway we knew
the government won't like it and
[Music]
so in the end you know the main role
he's living in Iran his son in the movie
he's living in Iran and we have some
other you know proof I mean backstage
from Iran
so yeah it just took like I met we met
more than 500 actors all over Europe and
in Europe and
um yeah and then the you know Ali had a
very special idea about this journalist
we were discussing a lot about these
journalists their motivations and and
you know even physically how she is and
we couldn't find her he wasn't happy
with
none of those actors as we met in Europe
and in Iran and finally after two years
of casting we met a young very talented
actress in Tehran and she was
she wanted to do it and you know I was
feeling that I just want her in this
project because I just felt that she
wants something more than you know she
wanted to change her professional life
and she wanted to do something bigger
than you know what she's doing in Iran
and she joined us in Jordan where we um
be there actually we shot in Jordan
and only a week before shooting
she changed her mind
I think at some point she got surprised
even with her own decision and just
feeling that okay this is just happening
and you're gonna be in it without your
hijab and Ali didn't want to censor it
you know we had this discussion if we
can do only because of two sin that's so
sad because
almost
outside and always with hijab only in
this these two scene in hotel room
actually she is with without her job
with shortened t-shirt and
and even for that we Ali didn't want to
you know we could change it somehow and
put something so then I became you know
the face of this movie and um that
journalist for me I I mean maybe because
I had this chance to work on the casting
for three years I knew her but I had
some questions about her and I never got
the answer when I was doing the casting
and when I just had this character in my
hand and started my own research and
just trying to find her in myself this
is the way I work always when I work on
a character I just try to find it in
first basic things in myself and then
work trying to because I believe
everyone has you know
any character can exist in us this is
what I believe and and somehow I just
started you know to call my journalist
friends who who were working at that
time in Iran and I heard their sad
stories about harassments and this
background with harassment actually it
with me came into the story and somehow
I you know I'm I linked my own
experience of life in around to this
character
and you know the whole process is the
whole journey of this movie for me is
just them like a miracle that's the
movie is existing today is a miracle I
became the main role is miracle and then
this hour for me you know as I said I
never stopped working in uh industry and
somehow I found my way and
you know I always was I had my hope I I
can do something
one day that that day will be there one
day and and that night in can sure it
was just like
some somehow a message of Justice yeah
in a world that almost you know you
think there is no justice
and that's fantastic and actually want
that to be your next movie if you could
do that is her story
um I do want to remind her when this
movie is in theaters now and it is a
very special film so please spread the
word thank you so much for being a great
audience and thank you both so much for
being here